[Musique]
produit du canada préparé au canada
importée par il est parfois difficile de
connaître la provenance de ce que l'on
mange ou
pour les fruits et légumes frais c'est
assez simple
ils soient emballés ou qu'ils soient en
vrac à il faut absolument qu est une
étiquette qui indique la provenance du
produit qu'il soit un produit canadien
ou importés il faut que ce soit
absolument clair pour la viande ça se
corse
si on vous vend une carcasse de boeuf
qui vient d'un autre pays
il devrait vous le dire mais on trouve
rarement des carcasses entières ou
supermarchés c'est par exemple une
carcasse et qu'on découpe la carcasse au
canada c'est une transformation canadel
et donc il n'y a pas d'obligation de
parler d'un produit importé donc pour
toutes les viandes
si ça arrive déjà emballée l'étiquetage
est obligatoire mais si ces découpes et
ici ça ne l'est pas pour les produits
transformés
quand c'est écrit produit du canada
c'est très clair on est donc certain que
tout ce qui à l'intérieur de de ceux
contenant l'eau vient du canada
si ces produits du canada absolument
donc non seulement l'intérieur et les
ingrédients doivent être canadien mais
la transformation en sauce à pizza doit
être fait dans deux compagnies
canadiennes avec de la main d'oeuvre
qu'abdel fabriqués ou préparer au canada
c'est moins clair si cette banane a été
mise en purée au canada même si c'est
une banale qui vient d'ailleurs c'est
pas un produit du canada mais il peut
être fabriqué au canada
donc c'est très différent c'est un
produit fabriqué au canada parce qu'on a
pris la banane on l'a mis en purée pour
des produits comme de la science c'est
encore moins évident
ça veut dire que les éléments ont été
mis ensemble et travailler en sauce au
canada mais est ce que chaque ingrédient
et canadien c'est une autre question
aucune façon donc de savoir d'où
viennent précisément les ingrédients sur
ce jus de pomme comme c'est écrit
préparer au canada et non produit du
canada
on peut supposer que certains
ingrédients ne viennent pas dit si on
pense que la pomme jules mots tout vient
de 10,6 du québec du canada
il se pourrait que ce soit pas le cas
absolument et en fait je vous dirais que
si un consommateur veut vraiment être
assurés qui mange un produit canadien
parce que c'est ce qui l'intéresse
à ce moment là qu'il faut qu'ils
recherchent l'étiquette qui va le
libellé qui va lui indiqué
qu'effectivement c'est un produit
canadien et ses produits du canada pour
tout le reste toutes les combinaisons
sont possibles dans le cas de ce jus de
pomme on sait que la sonde
s'approvisionne ici mais aussi en europe
et dans certains pays d'asie comme la
chine pour les produits qui arrivent
déjà transformé qu'ils soient emballées
ici ou ailleurs
la déclaration du pays d'origine est
obligatoire à ce moment là faut
absolument dire d'où est-ce qu'il est
importé soit on va dire importer par ou
pour où on va dire voilà la compagnie
d'attache canadienne mais c'est un
produit du brésil par exemple canada
canada de fantaisie c'est une
classification de qualité et de calibre
ça n'indique aucunement la provenance
même chose pour ce petit logo ça dit que
sa rencontre les normes de la loi sur
les viandes
donc je ne dis pas que ça vient du
canada samedi je sais inspecté au canada
c'est exactement ça super six et rien
écrit qu'est ce que ça nous dit si on
n'a rien
nice n'est capable de nous apporter ce
que ça vous dit fondamentalement c'est
que le produit est quand même un
produits salubres et que l'on peut
consommer sans aucun problème au canada
parce que les lois de la salubrité
alimentaire doivent être rencontrées
quel que soit l'étiquetage qui est
dessus mais quant aux choix personnels
de vouloir manger d'un endroit où de
l'autre ou d'éviter un produit ou un
autre ça ça devient effectivement plus
difficile
en attendant que le gouvernement
modernise sa loi sur l'étiquetage la
seule façon pour le consommateur de
savoir exactement d'où vient le produit
est d'entrer en contact avec le
fabricant le consommateur jouent un rôle
très actif et on lui recommande
d'appeler la compagnie pour avoir les
détails
[Musique]